good morning everybody I think we are
all set to begin thanks for coming this
morning to the third and final event of
this year's Tanner lectures
roundtable discussion it's been a
wonderful event so far and Sheila Ben
Bay and the middle research professor
from the University of the village
around in Johannesburg needs no further
introduction at this point joining him
this morning are two treasures from the
Yale faculty in DePaul rule is a
professor affiliated with several
programs women's gender and sexuality
studies where she is chair you still
care yes this is a race in migration
studies and the South Asian Studies
Council I think I've hit them all but
her latest book out just a few months
ago in fact from Duke is saving the
security state exceptional citizens in
21st century America
Michael Denning is the William R Kenan
jr. professor and likewise multiple--
affiliated with American Studies English
and ethnicity race and migration studies
he also co-directs the initiative on
labor and culture at Yale his latest
book from verso about a few years ago is
noise uprising the audio politics of a
world musical revolution a word about
how we'll proceed this morning
professors grew and Denning will each
speak briefly opening out some questions
and issues from the lectures you've
heard over the last two afternoons
professor and Bembe will respond and our
three panelists will then shape the
conversation as they wish after 50
minutes or so we'll open the
conversation to questions from the floor
and after that we'll adjourn to the
reception room straight down the hall
behind you for a light lunch and more
conversation thank you all for being
here
I guess they begin okay
so first to thank Gary for making this
happen for a shield for being here and
for giving two fantastic lectures that
resonated with some of the key questions
of the day and some of the key
theoretical issues that we grapple with
in studying race migration first
coloniality so what you said Sheila
spoke very much to many of our key
concerns not only topical but
theoretical research wise as well and
you know in in in the second lecture I
think one of the key issues that you
brought up was the question of migration
and the movement of Africans around
Europe and North America and what is
called the crisis of migration but
rather is a kind of scandal and a crime
migration one might say in Europe as
well so some of those questions really
spoke very loudly to us and and you
began in the first lecture we're talking
about the a very different kind of
paradigm of mobility that many of us
have been thinking about and trying to
grapple with not just in thinking about
the present and the ways in which
boundaries walls and the bounds of the
nation-state forms of power are not
enclosures but have have they are
permeable right that they're flight
they're moving they're mobile we're
grappling with the the kind of mobility
not just off capital of goods as you
said but also of persons but we're also
grappling with the mobility of things
that we thought were stable right but
kind of concepts of bounded
nation-states the idea of sovereignty
the idea of Westphalian state all of
these that you brought out so
importantly so one of the issues that
comes out of that is you what you
also spoke about in the first lecture
which is a question of sovereignty
where does sovereignty lie how does
sovereignty move how does it get you
know you referred to as ask assassins
talking about unbundled sovereignty and
you know the question there that I would
ask of you is you know looking back to
the work of Thomas Hanson and others
that who argues that's that the kind of
unbundling and dispersal of sovereignty
is not new that it was a condition of
colonialism as well so one of the issues
that I would want to ask you to say more
about is the question of not just about
the unbundling of sovereignty but the
paradigm of nobility is it new should we
have thought about it as a question of a
changing formation of nation-state or do
we think about it in terms of a paradigm
shift in which we have always not
addressed thus the mobility of people
right that mobility is something that
has always been there but the kind of
emergence of the Westphalian state and
all of these other bounded enclosure
making processes and disciplinarity have
not allowed us to see it in some ways
and that we're grappling with it so
that's one of the questions that would
be really helpful for us not just in
thinking about the politics but the
organization of knowledge as well in the
university for instance but
disciplinarity the area states and
national boundaries as as enclosures of
thought as well of knowledge so some of
that would be that's one question that I
would ask a second question I think is
something that you brought up also
really importantly that I've been
gapping with is about security regimes
that securitisation of borders of people
is is sort of this condition of the
present where development has been
securitized everything is becoming
securitized now and you you spoke about
that as well but one of the complex
things about security is that I think
there's an effective notion of security
as well where people desire some kind of
settlement where people desire a care
welfare in particular kinds of spaces
and when you spoke of the kind of
utopian thought of mobility of people
being able to move everywhere one of the
things we'd come up again the question
yesterday that Alicia was also asking
what do we do with people who want to
settle who wants something from a state
who want documents who want Social
Security who won't care who want all of
these things so that would be another
question to think about a third would be
the question of technology how do we
think of surveillance and technology as
again not just something a new kind of
project but rather that technology
produces fears and is always harness
toward certain ideological and as well
so how is what you talked about as the
cellular and fragmented way in which
surveillance and technology are are
produced sort of it part of a longer
history right put-put
you know the kind of fingerprints are a
colonial apparatus so we have these for
a really long time so how do we think of
those as well as being part of a history
of colonialism that you you know have
shed so much light on and helped us
understand in so many ways so I guess
that some of those would be key
questions to think about in terms of
habitation abode the question of
settling the question of people wanting
to be in certain places and and my last
point would
the kind of question of the verticality
of power that you spoke of
you know White's men and others have
talked about the way we need to think of
power not just as horizontal or lateral
but as from the sky down right that
satellites and technologies allow us to
think of cities and places and a whole
different kind of optic as well and of
course he uses an it in terms of kind of
diagnosing human rights abuses and power
but I wonder how you would think about
that verticality of power in relation to
technology in relation to the kind of
post-colonial project of migration and
enclosure that you were also trying to
you know grappling with and questioning
in all kinds of ways so I would put out
those first of all I would like to thank
in the platter for having been here
having attended the lectures and having
so attentively and so carefully drawn
out the four pragmatics she has just
shared with with us all of which I think
extremely useful for any discussion on
on question of mobility in in our times
I think you are absolutely right to
insist on the necessity for grounding
all of this in in deeper history or
deeper histories for that matter a
condition I agree for eliciting possibly
what what might be new in all that we
are we are seeing right now and longer
history of technologies law
history of forms of of power longer
history of questions you raise such as
national boundaries enclosures more
modes of thought and forms of production
of knowledge so I'll try to not really
respond but just rebound on on what it
is that I have I've heard from you the I
don't think the novelty is about
technologies as such talking about
technologies in particular the the the
novelty stems from I would argue a face
of the history of capitalism many have
characterized as a phase of acceleration
the novelty lies in the the fact of our
having domesticated speed at a level and
seen before I really believe that this
question of speed of velocity is what is
if there is anything new that is it I
was referring his day to the work of
Paul Virilio in particular since he is
one of those who have helped us some
extent to understand the centrality of
speed in the making and remaking of our
world speed domestication of speed as it
is related to the in particular this
question of of light I mentioned
yesterday almost in passing I think
I should have been more on that because
a number of technologies adduced to war
warfare security for that matter but
also the production of of wealth in this
age of financial capitalism most of them
indeed maximizing forms of maximization
of of speed they rely on speed the new
forms of capitalism rely on speed I
refer to algorithmic trading a number of
new studies of those forms of exchange
that show indeed extent to which they in
fact learned early as a serial
repression of speed so speed seems to me
to be the novelty and the organizing
principle for their forms of life we
were referring to now if indeed speed is
becoming the resource for the remaking
of our world it goes without saying that
the that the ultimate forms of
sovereignty the most efficient ways of
exercising power have to do with how to
capture speed and how to redistribute
speed in an equal voice who are those
who must go slow if you want to put it
like that and who are those who might
not be able to move who are those who
might be able to move
at a speed with a velocity that is an
equally it seems to me that that's how
we have to frame these questions in this
age as far as the organization of
knowledge is concerned and a lot of our
knowledge in in the humanities in the
social sciences and probably in other
fields is predicated on instead entirety
it is predicated on people settled
somewhere moving of course back but
moving from within a space that is
delimited as fundamentally and enclosed
locations places so forth and so on so
so our knowledge mirrors somewhat this
partition of the world that is
predicated on our own said entirety and
if indeed we live in an era of as I was
suggesting is the planetary entanglement
obviously this requires different
different forms of production of
knowledge itinerant knowledge for
instance it requires a new imagination
of institutions university that wouldn't
have walls for instance university
beyond walls knowledge beyond walls and
these experiments are already being
there are places where such
experimentations are going on where
people experimenting with forms of
knowledge that would not be bounded
either nationally originally forms of
knowledge that would secret knowledge is
in circulation it seems to me that is
the challenge this kind of analysis
poses one last thing verticality of
power is a hybrid yell yells work and
and in fact hazel raised the same issue
informally the other night at a dinner
what about the vertical that which comes
from the sky how do we take into
consideration not only the sea or the
desert but also the air and I think it's
a very important question but what
strikes me is that in fact is the fact
that it's the every articulations of all
these optical points of view it's not
the privileges of the the sky as such no
is it the privileges of terrestrial or
the maritime it's the process of
conversion of the maritime into the
terrestrial the terrestrial into sky
it's that circulation between different
optical points of view which seems to me
to be going on and which seems to me to
be producing an entirely new paradigm of
power sovereignty and domination and the
transformation of all of this into into
codes and indeed including the
transformation of the human itself into
into into code and into a date and
therefore the the the distance let's say
the living behind us of all moral
the human which with which we the
humanities have been working and there
is the human appended to to an object
the human appended to an animal the
human appended to different other
species beings and all that captured
into codes and data that is what seems
to me to be real the neurology so long
and tortures answer to your question is
so can I press you in one years which is
that some people some thinkers are
talking about in the mention of
algorithms that is now sovereign is what
is sovereign is data that we're now
thinking about an unbundling of
sovereignty we have what they see is
that kind of sovereignty of data but on
the other hand summary is one kind of
racial algorithm different argument also
suggests that that data is not that
sovereign all on its own that's informed
by the verities it is absolutely
informed it is shaped and reshaped by
various other other factors including
race gender class and the rest is not
neutral no is it objective it's not at
all objective I could continue but let
me ask a couple of other questions which
I think are actually from the other side
of your account of geopolitics and
biopolitics
you know you gave us powerful I want to
thank you for the powerful account of
the mobile and portable border the way
border work and border processing and
border enforcement can move anywhere in
some ways and is now in the interstices
of daily life and it made me think of
how across the traffic routes in
particular where mobile beings move not
only airports with their various
security lines which were so aware but I
was thinking indeed of roads and
highways with their speed cameras
they're easy passes the rules of the
road that have actually made driver's
licence is such an important
issue for undocumented workers and for
migrants in that kind of way and also my
to want to thank you for that powerful
assertion of the right of all mobile
mammals to move around the earth to
extend as you said to the poor members
of the earth that taken for granted
rights of the US passport but I wonder
whether the issue of borders and the
question of movement are really the same
question because it's as you yourself
put it the business of a border to be
crossed and movement might be nothing
more than the crossing of borders I was
thinking this morning as I crossed from
the town of guilford into the city of
New Haven that moment when we crossed
the border from Connecticut in New York
and see the looming towers of Manhattan
then that sort of excitement and and
whether or not borders are really about
movement or the issue of free movement
then as you also said at one point about
the ways of classifying people and if
what you mean by a borderless world is
not a world of free movement but a world
of not where people are not classified
and that that might be a different way
to think this so let me ask two
questions in the following that one on
the bio politics and geopolitics of
sovereignty which you raised and one on
what might one might call the bio
economics and geo economics of
accumulation so at first I'm kind of
intrigued to hear more about the
implications of Ghana's right to abode
as a kind of refiguring what what are
the philosophical implications of that
refiguring of sovereignty which from my
very quick study seems to involve two
different aspects one is the right of
gun anne's to move freely in ghana
the right to leave and enter ghana
immunity from expulsion from ghana
exactly the right that i had to drive
from Guildford to New York or to
California in that
but secondly and more remarkably the
extension of that right in the act of
2000 as I understand it to a person of
African descent in the Diaspora that's
the quote and so this a write that
includes the right to remain
indefinitely the right to work without a
work permit the right to come without a
visa the right to have children and
dependents covered by that same abode
and so I guess my question is do you
raise this as fundamentally a part of a
politics of reparations is this really a
sense of repairing the forced
confinement the chained migration of the
Atlantic slave trade the divisions of
the continent you talked about in Berlin
or is this a sense that the full freedom
of movement of mammal human mammals
depends perhaps less on an abstract call
for open borders than on the repair of
specific migratory circuits historical
circuits on the reforging of the lengths
of what our president has denounced as
chain migration and the second question
so that's all one question I guess you
powerfully begin both days with the
question to whom does the earth belong
and who determines its partition and
distribution and yet your answers
focused vitally no doubt on the borders
that were maintained by sovereign states
but doesn't the question of the
partition of the earth also depend as
much on the partition of the earth as
different capital as private property
owned by transnational corporations with
no trespassing signs their border work
that's done by an army of security
guards often staffed by those mobile
migrants in they disproportionately with
the temporary issuing of permits and
passes to get on to those spaces as well
as the gated communities of private
homeowners again both of those
in some ways outside the state again
serviced by the labor of migrants but
who are off-limits to those ones and I
guess that was so I would wonder how
does one imagine and this is really to
return to Alicia's question which I
won't try to repeat but I'll actually
just quote her from a written piece
because I couldn't read but how do we
imagine a new mobility of humans that
isn't simply the flexibility of labour
for the movement of capital but a new
kind of in here's where I'm quoting her
a new kind of migrant justice that would
allow migrants to achieve and exercise
social power without obtaining formal
citizenship where migrants would be
binational civic actors whether some
kind of space between not being a
citizen of being a citizen and whether
that raises and I guess the final
question then is partly you quite
provocative suggested that mobility was
the motor of social and economic change
and not actually internal struggles
inside a society and I was intrigued at
whether having thought so long and hard
about changes in twentieth-century South
Africa and across the South African
continent is it true what what were the
forms of mobility that actually caused
those social transformations and
economic transformations so as to see
how migrants might in the 21st century
so reshape the world
these are all very interesting comments
and questions the the speak first
brought the the right of a boat since
you you picked it up as a key element of
yesterday's presentation I don't think
that in the Ghanaian understanding it is
conceived as being part of the fourth
freedom we spoke about yesterday it's
not at least not immediately thought of
in in those terms in terms of Ghana or
Africa for that matter being able to
institute a regime of flexible labor
market labor circulation and so forth so
on that is taken care of by the treaty
that has just been signed in Kigali
which are referred to yesterday the
single market treaty which would allow
possibly the movement of labor from
places a production to - to the rest so
the right to abode now encompasses a
number of aspects it is
its aim is to make sure as you indicated
that Ghanaians
and Africans in general or people of
African descent take ownership of this
specific space called Africa Ghana being
one instance iation of of that larger
space which would mean they have the
right to to come in they have the right
to settle they have the right to work
they have the right to be taken care of
insofar as the state attends to matters
of of of care and they have the right to
come and go but the right of abode is
also understood as a specific right
extended to people of African origin not
for as a result of historical
circumstances have happened to be
located elsewhere it is similar in that
sense to the right of return
Israel has instituted for Jewish people
Jewish Diaspora
and you're absolutely right to suggest
that there is a reparative element in it
and an implicit recognition of the
responsibility of African powers in the
whole business of the Atlantic slave
trade in particle
but these reparative element is also has
to do with self reparation and in fact
in the juridical debates that preceded
the adoption of this specific article of
the Constitution that reparative
dimension was explicitly spoken about so
it seems to me that a concept of the
right to abode is somewhat of a response
in the part to the question you were
asking telling some people want to
settle some people want to to be taken
care of so it's part of all of that it's
part of an attempt at making sure that
people of African descent or African
people find on this earth that
presumably belongs to all a place where
they do not have to justify who they are
why they are there and what they are
doing there
where to be black is no longer liability
because they doesn't seem to be such a
place in a world right now away you are
not forced to justify why you are black
so the right of abode would be that
mechanism that allows you to not have to
be classified and to not have to justify
why you are who you are that's how I I
would expand
the concept of reparation when applied
to these specific type of right you also
write to suggest that there are various
modalities of partition of the earth we
have the Westphalian model where states
apportion parts of the earth and
distributed among themselves but there
are other modalities that are not
suggesting the esteem will be not
strongly enough operated by the works of
capital in a place like such as
Johannesburg in the aftermath of a party
urban planning by governmental agencies
hardly operates in alone the city is
rebuilt basically by private agencies
they decide where they want to create
new suburbs they build roads they give
names to the boulevards and the avenues
and in buildings as new suburbs they
reproduce the mechanisms of segregation
or they ratify the modes of
redistribution of urban space which used
to operate under a person or not so so
it's no longer just the property of the
state capital is very much involved in
making remaking or and making borders
what forms of mobility might cause what
types of transformations
this is a interesting sociological
question yeah
in the in the in the South African case
in fact the the collapse of a party it
was the result of people mobilizing of
course via political activities but it
was also the result of the collapse of
the the past the past system the past
system was a system whereby South Africa
was carved into internal
borders because blacks were not citizens
of the South African state because they
were citizens of the bantu stands they
needed permits to come and work in those
places where they could find jobs they
were not City residents as such at a
certain point during the day I think
five o'clock or 5:30 they were supposed
to leave the city and go and reside in
specific places that were located
especially to them their presence in the
city necessitated the possession of a
pass so what happens by the mid-80s is
massive campaign of disobedience where
people decide they are no longer going
to carry passes and you have an influx
the influx control laws collapse
entirely in flux control laws way the
laws regulating internal migrations
within South Africa itself lost which
way racially of course
configured it collapses people go into
cities in Johannesburg for instance
instance the most cosmopolitan
neighborhood Hillbrow which was peopled
inhabited early on especially by people
from the Jewish Diaspora it's
overwhelmed by the arrival of those who
are not supposed to be there that's how
a party becomes partly and government in
addition goes to the manipulation of
unleashing of insurrectionary violence
so we see in this instance how it is
that the capacity for people to move
changes the urban configuration it
changes completely the ways in which the
apparatus of capture which is the state
operates and leads to to change let's
see
social transformations but I'm sure it
could extend this example to other
others as well in the continent or so so
just to finish on that I think that
there is a migrants have bearers of
specific transformation capacities we
haven't examined seriously migrants see
is probably one of those resources those
who would like to change the world today
should invest in eliciting and
unleashing how that's the topic for the
next Anna lecture I guess we should open
it up to the last question Michael read
the quote from Alisha which sort of
suggests a different kind of moving my
the migrant away from capture by labor
and capital to something else and I'm
wondering about the kind of ways in
which European modernity took mobility
as as Liberty because it came from
modernist notions of exile itinerants
adventure all of those things so one of
the shadows if one might say of mobility
is that sort of colonial history of
mobility as well right and and so the
struggle it seems to me in what Alicia
is saying Michael C is is how to how to
take that shadow away from migration one
hand of capital one hand of sort of a
link to European kind of project of you
know modernity to somewhere else and
what that might be is indeed utopian but
how to imagine that utopia is I think
the kind of struggle that we're dealing
with right and what constitutes mobility
as the engine of that is the other
question I think what one would have to
take some very specific cases to answer
this as I was suggesting yesterday in
pre-colonial Africa mobility was the
norm it was really the known in some
societies what was not normal
was the sedentary the fact of settling
in a place and being in the same place
from generation to generation
you even have historical
talking about fiction historical
examples of kingdoms that were moving
kingdoms that you-you-you kingdoms that
were not limited to one Terrace they
were constantly in motion the same thing
with trade caravans when the concept of
a caravan applied not only to trade but
also to political formations things were
on motion was the enormous if you want
that was the law and once again these
are historical examples in West Africa
in central Africa present-day Congo
Angola and that kingdoms moving from the
Atlantic coast towards the Indian Ocean
and changing in the context bringing on
board new people capturing new religions
instituting new social relations and
anesthetic forms so that was the earth
now when we talk about mobility and
colonialism the colonial logic in that
context these how it operates first of
all it operates on the basis of
settlement settlement along the coast to
begin with entre posed that the
combination of warfare and trade and
mission izing Christianity these are the
three so so it operates in on the basis
of partition of territory that is first
of all imagined because it has no
borders as such it's progressively that
borders are instituted in
with local inhabitants but mostly in
negotiation with other European powers
all of which culminates with the Berlin
conference which I referred to in the
first night so it's a patchy thing
absolutely open-ended
Messi's not has no rationale you have
borders I mean you take a rule and
basically you trace a line it doesn't
matter what is there it's a big line if
you have a map of Africa look at for
instance the border between Algeria and
Mali it's just like this it cuts through
a pre-existing territory that was
totally fluid cause was the Sahara
Desert
totally nomadic people seek little of
that boom you put a rule same thing with
the border between Angola and Botswana a
straightforward line no consideration of
anything people mountains rivers some
borders consider rivers and physical
markers but others don't so so that is
what happens with colonialism and then
when the colonial state is properly
instituted after conquest and occupation
and when it's operating it needs them to
regulate people's movements and the
movement of goods the movement of goods
is unidirectional you have the
hinterland and you have the coast
anything produced in the hinterland has
to go through the course and shipped
outside the extractive economy we have
today which is at the basis therefore of
the regulation of of movements so you
have pores where let's see here they
specialized in the production of cotton
over the fraction of palm oil and you
need labour
to be working in these units and the
biggest problem of colonialism in the
continent was the problem of labor
because they were they didn't seem to
ever be enough laborers I mean South
Africa has is absolutely the case they
have to go outside of South African
Mozambique in Malawi in in in in places
as far as Zambia Zimbabwe southern Congo
to bring labor to work in the mines in
the Witwatersrand and in so doing you
create original constellation with
regulated movements because these are
seasonal workers the common go borders
don't really matter that much in the
case of southern Africa they matter and
they don't they matter because of the
politics of states but they don't
because the economic demand requires
that they be open so the business of the
current state is to simultaneously
institute borders but render them
flexible enough to make it possible for
the process of accumulation to to keep
going on so so what is it that I want to
see in relation to your question I think
that we have to do a proper case study
kind of exercise in order to elicit the
many different ways in which colonialism
makes remakes and make makes borders so
inherit or all of that and in fact I
believe that people within the continent
were able to move more freely under
colonialism than then after colonialism
what we see after colonialism is a
crystallization of state borders the
emergence of the border becomes a rent
it becomes a rent for those social
classes that control the state they use
it to extract rents which was not the
case under colonialism which aggravates
let's say diminishes Africans
possibilities of moving freely within
their own continent so it's a long
response but it just shows the extent to
which I think when we say colonialism
there are many different and then we'll
throw it out it's just your earlier
discussion of speed and acceleration
because it might seem that actually
acceleration and speed makes location
and space much more important so that
they the response to the speed at light
of algorithmic trading is that you
actually have to be located even closer
to Wall Street because of the micro
seconds that the time that it takes to
be engage in that and they're in many
ways that the acceleration that you were
talking about in speed means that one
has to be more tightly connected to the
infrastructure of speed whether that is
airports or data lines or interstates or
whatever that makes it much more
difficult for people who are what you
called go slow but are actually perhaps
walking had a normal human face not just
speed but perhaps scale so the the
potentiality of algorithmic trading is
its ability to capture vast amounts of
money by scaling out quite just pennies
and fractions but they're so large in a
human scale that they becomes so the
scalar advancement it seems to me are
critical in this as well and the
connection was simply under your owning
explanation of how the infrastructure of
the ports which at one sense was an
acceleration and a speeding up of moving
commodities around the world actually
ended up prohibiting earlier forms of
mobility thank you very much I'm my name
is Mary Ellen Tucker at the environment
school I'm sorry I couldn't come to the
other lectures because of teaching so
this question would relate to migration
due to climate change or environmental
issues both in North Africa and now what
we're seeing in South Africa because of
water depletion and so on so I wonder if
you might have touched onto this already
but I'd love to have your comments on
this because there's 19 million refugees
for climate change alone now around the
world but clearly the African continent
has been particularly severely hit by
drought and other issues it's a
combination of many many different
factors some of them are ecological and
environmental but some of these
ecological or environmental factors
themselves the product of human human
induced at astrophys for instance the
year the wars in the Great Lakes region
which comprises the Congo Rwanda Burundi
Uganda according to the UN have caused
millions of victims over
a very short period of time when you add
the genocide in Rwanda and all that has
been going on the wars of predation
in the eastern Congo a few million
people but they have also caused serious
environmental consequences
which were not there before the war so
the war produces ecological catastrophes
which in turn result in further further
Wars most of them was of extraction
cobalt means when every time you open
your computer a lot of your computer
parts of your computer they are coming
from from they they are coming from the
Kumu the your computer to a large extent
is made up of wealth mineral wealth
extracted from the Congo as a result of
the miniaturization of of the economy
militarization para militarization of
the economy the two combined so the
extractive part and the abstract part
all together linked in a continuum we do
not study because we study economics of
extraction as if they were just located
there and the finance financialization
as part of Wall Street but there is a
link between Wall Street and eastern
Congo so so so people migrate for all
kinds of reasons mean in Johannesburg
who have been living in Johannesburg for
the last 17 years and we see the city
changing entire neighbourhoods people
only speak in Lingala urban some other
languages from the rest of the continent
these are people who some of them are
running away from
terrible political systems others are
coming because they want to make a
living they will live better they will
earn live little more they will send
money to the places where they come from
so so the the reasons are many they are
busy I mean it's a serious matter of
course the question of water and water
politics is is a geopolitical question
it's in South Africa it is the result of
long years of drought it's also the
result of I would say bad bad planning
we know very well that big big issue for
parts of South Africa is water
they have been attempts at directing
capturing parts of the water in the
Congo and linking it up with southern
Africa it is possible the studies have
been done there's not enough political
will to do so so it's all of that but
the ecological question clearly is in
some parts of the world at the heart of
process of migration it's not the only
one so thank you and thank you all for
your kind references to my thing on this
work I want to say again thank you for
me the these lectures have been
extraordinary invitations to expand our
imaginary the political imaginary the
ethical imaginary and so I wanted to ask
you to perhaps in I found your
invocation of the Dogon and the network
systems and the debt systems very
illuminating for showing us other forms
of social relations tied to land and
and kinship and membership to this place
and I wondered how that might be placed
in conversation with the traditions of
African socialism so as to think about
another piece of the hostility and
racism imbued by colonialism not only in
Africa but the Americas in in Australia
against the Aboriginal populations that
mobile people were represented as more
primitive not only because they would
not conform to the sedentary order the
imperative of being sedentary but
because they seemed to be people who
could not be productive users of land
because they did not accumulate and the
imperative in the post-colonial era of
as you've written about beautifully is a
new administrative control of the
economies of the former colonized
nations by insisting and demanding
certain modes of production accumulation
so I just I wanted to ask you if there's
a way to connect the vision that you
gave us around the pre-colonial social
worlds and forms of habitation to
another vision of a African socialism
which is also rich tradition thank you
okay they have been historical
experience of socialism in in the
continent since the end of colonialism
different kinds of experiments in Guinea
Conakry in Angola in Mozambique in even
in Senegal Senghor for instance was a
major theorist of African socialism and
of course in Tanzania Tanzania was the
most advanced experiment in that sense
with Herrera and his concept of JAMA and
most of those experiments have failed
foreign quote they have failed to extend
not today hardly and you hardly find
anybody even doing research on so-called
African socialism's
most of these from its a theoretical
ideological point of view most of these
experiments we're aiming at
domesticating let's say Marx basically
they were part of a project of
domestication of Marx in the conditions
of Africa and there the overall premise
was that these African societies were
governed by the law of community
distinction between what is commoner and
or is individual and that property
relations were hardly privatized
property relations were communal land
belonged to a community rather than to
individuals there was an element of this
that was true and another element that
was highly mythical but no politics it's
about truth it's also about myth nothing
wrong with that now you are asking me to
make a link between auras
seriously right African paranal
geometrics and the idea of African
socialism I don't think there was a
direct connection talking about these
historical experiments there was hardly
any any connection there was an exercise
of
reinvention of traditions or some
elements of so-called traditions for
purposes of political efficacy and
otherwise what I was trying to say was
that if we look at the different call
them archives of the world something we
could call the African archive to be
defined on that if we look at the
different archives of the world this
allows us to imagine let's see different
paradigms of almost everything of how
gender relations can be organized how it
is the property relations are organized
what types of relations people have with
the divine religious field there's a
multiplicity of paradigms if we think in
terms of the planetary in terms of the
humanity as a whole which are not
reducible to those paradigms that end up
dominating our mostly Western parada
parents coming from one form of human
experience so the converse to in this
age when we are so interconnected we
cannot produce knowledge that is simply
provincial what our world requires now
forms of knowledge that are as much as
possible
a manifestation of the multiplicities of
the archives we inherit so if the debate
is about how to govern mobility in this
century we
by the way by the end of this century
the biggest number of people in our
world will be coming from the continent
of Africa
by 2050 Africa will have recovered the
demographic gap it suffered during the
Atlantic slave trade and by the end of
the century most living beings human
beings on earth will be found in the
continent Nigeria will be bigger
demography speaking than the United
States of America the youngest people on
earth will be coming from they will have
a kind of map of the world population in
which the oldest people and the smaller
number of people will be located in
places such as here Europe Japan of
course partly Latin America and the
biggest number of youngest people will
be coming from Asia and particularly
Africa so the question of who owns the
earth how do we divide it how do we
apportion it will be resolved partly
through the demographic calculus so
demography will become geopolitics it's
already YZ and naturally what we will
see is a process which is already going
on we call it migration crisis whatever
that's the wrong term what is going on
is a process of I don't know the term in
English in French it is her problem oh
no problemo is the process of is also
like under colonialism colonialism was a
form of her palma of the world people go
into
Australia South Africa Asia um that it
won't happen like that by the end of
this century
it won't happen like that because we are
beyond colonialism unless we go and
colonize another planet but it will
happen through population move people
moving the key is it will be unlocked by
people moving in spite of borders that's
how the the earth will be repealed if
you want I don't know what the term hope
problemo means in English you will find
it but that's what I'm talking about so
now if you want to understand therefore
that process it seems to me we have to
open as many archives as possible so the
question of the government of human
mobility in this century cannot be
resolved exclusively by looking into the
anti-humanist archive of the West
because when it comes to borders
people's movements the Western archive
is anti-human it is pro capital even pro
commodity the question of the fourth
freedom it privileges things over people
in the continent if we look at the
archive of the continent people and
things are interwoven you cannot allow
things to move freely without allowing
people to go with them because if you
separate people from things you destroy
both people and things you make the
earth and inhabitable so the question of
the 21st century is that all question of
the right to abort the right to inhabit
the entirety of the planet and return
when as we see almost everywhere many
bows are being rendered and
inhabitable for those who are they
that's why they want to live they want
to live because the aboard has been
rendered and inhabitable so the question
is how do we recover some sense of
habitability whereas I was arguing
earlier on I don't have to justify Who I
am and why I look the way I look it
entails the end of classification the
end of classification as the opening of
the world to all who inhabit it people
and things so that's what I mean the
whole exercise that is what it was I I
want to say that we do have more
opportunity for conversation in the
reception to come and it seems to me
that that extraordinary summarizing
statement an extraordinary summarizing
statement not a utopian one but
nonetheless a futuristic one and one
that shows us the amazing challenges to
humanity as a whole that you are posing
to us that that has to be a place where
we stop this part of the conversation at
least and and move on so thank you so
much to our main speaker our shield and
Ben Bay and to our panelists in the talk
and light
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]